it's all news to me but okay I was
trying to achieve this okay thanks for
coming again this is a continuation of
what we're talking about yesterday and
today I'm going to focus on a few graph
problems and we'll try to see some
reductions showing some equivalences and
some hardness so I'm let me first start
with the graph problems i'm going to
consider in this talk here let's for
this talk will just think of an
undirected graph is going to have
weights on the edges and will have n
nodes and damages okay so the first
problem i'm going to talk about is
completing the eccentricities of the
graph so what is an eccentricity for
each node its eccentricity is the
maximum distance out of it so you look
at all the distances from X to all the
other nodes and you take the maximum
there's the eccentricity of X now given
that we know what eccentricities are we
can now define the perp you more
parameters one of them is the diameter
this is the maximum eccentricity also
known as the maximum distance in the
graph then we also have the minimum
eccentricity which is the radius of the
graph so the center of a graph is a node
that has you can reach all the notes
within the minimum distance and this
minimum distance for which and out can
reach all the other nodes is called the
radius of a graph and it's the minimum
eccentricity okay now there's a
different parameter that doesn't use the
notion of eccentricity but it's still
very widely studied is the median of a
graph which is just the minimum over all
nodes X of the sum of the distances out
of X so instead of taking the maximum
distance out of X now just some of them
so this is like finding a node that has
minimum average distance to everything
hello we have these four things and we
can ask what is the fastest algorithm
and unfortunately the best algorithms we
have or just to compute all the
distances in the graph and then you
follow the definitions and then you get
or what the parameters are so this turns
out to be for dense grass we get roughly
and cubed and for sparse graphs we get
roughly and squared where sparse here on
my name is roughly an M is root or
they're just here okay so then the
natural question is why should we be
spending so much time especially for
these three three things here we only
really have to complete a single number
we're not competing n squared distances
we only only care about one of them why
should it take as much time as all pair
shortest paths and so will investigate
this okay and in general can we suppose
we it's difficult maybe to do to get sub
cubic algorithms for all pair shortest
path but maybe for these parameters we
could do better maybe for DES grass you
can to get them to the three minus
epsilon maybe four spots we can get them
to 2 minus epsilon so okay and people
have tried this for a long long time and
we haven't succeeded and then okay so
let's do what we usually do let's relax
the problem a little bit and so we then
we can ask another question what if we
just want to approximate the answers can
we do a little better okay so this is
this is a question is that I'm going to
talk about so in the rest of the talk
i'm going to just split the talking to
two pieces the first part i'll talk
about dense graphs and the second part
i'll talk about sparse graphs for
whatever reason the techniques that we
use for dense graphs and sparse graphs
are different and one lope and question
is to try to do something about that and
bring these techniques to get well think
about this later okay
all right let's start with a dense graph
case so again recall their we're
computing all pair shortest paths this
is the best thing we know how to do and
we don't really know how to do it is
substantially faster than n cube time
and Ryan and I here and then with a mere
for breath you and Fabrizio we show the
following theorem which is that if you
care about beading cubic time by a
polynomial factor then all pair shortest
path is actually equivalent to radius
median and many other problems okay so
we have we've shown that in the desk
case two of the parameters we discussed
are actually equivalent to all pair
shortest paths in the sense that if you
had an end to the three minus epsilon
algorithm for one of the problems then
the other problems also have an end to
three minus Delta time outlet so i will
recap what I said yesterday but in the
context of cubic reduction sub cubic
reductions and I change the picture a
little bit to make things a little bit
more clear so a sub cubic reduction from
problem a to problem B is an algorithm
this is the algorithm this arrow it
takes an instance of problem a then once
an algorithm that produces instance is a
problem being and you these instances
they may be produced adaptively
depending on the answers so these
instances you feat to some algorithm and
depending on what the algorithm says you
may change what the next instance it
look like but no matter what this this
algorithm does no matter what sequence
of these instances you produce you
guarantee that when you take their sizes
to be n 1 and 2 and so on the sum of the
end sub i's to the 3 minus epsilon is
less than n to the 3 minus Delta so when
you do this what do you get you get that
if you have an
into the three minus epsilon algorithm
for B then you get an end to 3 minus
Delta algorithm from a by running the
reduction and summing up the wrong times
for the bees which is exactly exactly
follow this so okay so this is the type
of reduction we're going to show and in
fact I will give you an example where we
actually produce a lot of instances of
be adaptively so this is not always the
case often we actually only produce one
instance but but for the example i'm
going to show you actually need to do
this it so pair shortest paths is
equivalent to radius and mediate for
this for the purposes of this talk and
also eccentricities okay so let me flash
the slide again just in case you weren't
aware of the long long research of all
pair shortest path it has been a
notoriously difficult problem to improve
on and cubed small improvements have
been possible but they have been really
really hard to obtain a new techniques
have been developed with all these
papers and in the end Ryan even through
complexity of the problem and still you
only get something that's less than
polynomial it's it beats all Polliwogs
though so it's a huge step towards what
we want but we're still stuck so and
this essentially shows that if we did
the same on these parameters we have the
same problem it's a little discouraging
but maybe it's not that discouraging
because now we can just attack these
simply looking problems and maybe they
have more structure okay so there's this
conjecture that I mentioned yesterday
which says let's say let's take the word
drive model we order log n bit words and
they're all pair shortest paths is
conjectured to taken to the three-
little of one time
okay so here's a few more problems we've
shown to be equivalent to a pair
shortest path here's all pair shortest
path there's something called the
distance product that I will define it
has been known for a long time that
these problems are actually equivalent
they have exactly the same complexity
within constant factors and all of these
arrows here they signify reductions from
the problem to a problem and David they
were all known just because all of these
problems they're just special cases of
operations path we can just use an
algorithm to solve them so median we
define the winner index is just the sum
of all of the distances on a graph now
between the centrality is something
about how central vertexes so it says
roughly how many shortest paths go
through this vertex actually it's the
fraction and you have to the weight it a
little bit but it's a very important
problem in social network analysis so it
turns out that we can put it on the
board here replacement pass here you're
given the shortest path between two
vertices s and T and you want to know
for every edge on this shortest path
what would the new shortest path between
smtp if i were to remove this edge and
this problem is not too hard to reduce
to a pair shortest path but it also
turns out to be equivalent as well see
okay second shortest path is an even
simpler problem which is i mentioned it
yesterday instead of computing the
shortest path between two nodes we now
want to know what's the second one
second shortest path on the list of
shoppers pass by distance radius we
defined distance product verification
distance product is some sort of matrix
product that i'll define mr. produce
verification just asks given two
matrices and a third one tell me of the
distance product of the first two equals
the third one
and so on so these are the problems here
so how did we show equivalences well we
showed a reduction in the opposite
direction between this problem which I
haven't defined yet and distance product
so this problem is actually a very very
simple problem you're given a graph and
it has edge weights and you want to find
three vertices that are all connected to
each other so a triangle and the sum of
the edge race has to be negative and
it's a decision problem this is such an
object exists or not and it turns out
that under sub cubic reductions distance
product is equivalent to negative
triangle and because negative triangle
is so simple you get all these other
arrows and then you can complete the
picture and I owe you you can see this
is strongly connected Griffin ok so this
is where we're going to try to show I'm
just going to show you two arrows in
this picture I'll show you this one and
i will show you mention what this is I
think it's pretty nice to see and i'll
show you the one to radius any questions
up to this point
yes
yes we did this fine grade reduction I
showed that on the previous slide and
you'll see examples of it so and their
equivalent in the sense that if you get
into the 2.9 now we're over one of them
may be getting an end to the 2.99 line
for the others but you preserve super
capacity so in this case now start with
defining distance product and giving you
some idea of why do I its equivalent to
all pair shortest path the distance
product is as follows you're given two
matrices a and B and you can think about
the usual matrix product except that now
I replace the Sun with a min and the
product with a plus so it's the min / kv
ik + b KJ it's also called min plus
product all right so if you had an atty
event time algorithm for all pair
shortest path then you can also solve
the product in the same time and this is
not too hard to do the word the way you
do it is let's say I'm given two
matrices a and B I can just build a
graph out of them in the following way
it's going to be tripartite and I'll
just layer put them as layers left
middle and right and I'll put edges from
the left to the middle with where the
weight and I'll put an weight over the
edge which could correspond to the entry
in matrix a there will be no no edge
whenever its infinity okay now for the
edges between the middle and the right I
put the weight of them corresponding to
matrix B so it looked at the on the edge
of from k to jail have the KJ entry of B
and on the edge from I to K hero have
the IQ entry of a and now this graph is
directed from left to right and if I
compute the shortest path between every
note here and every note
here I will actually get exactly the
entry of the mentalist product to the
discipline because for this graph the
distances are just the minimum weights
of passive like to from left to right
and then this this is exactly the
medicinal
okay so you can also go in the other
direction in the following way okay so
what do you do you make some
observations first thing is I'm just
going to take my graph and i'll create a
matrix out of it as usual and the way
you do it you put an infinity when
there's no edge between UV you put zero
and your equals V and the weight of the
edge otherwise and now with the success
of squaring okay and you notice that if
we compute the case power of this matrix
under the distance product you'll get
the weight of the shortest path on there
has at most K edges so when you 22 when
you multiply it once you'll get to two
edges just as look on the previous slide
and so on and you can compute a to decay
with successive squaring with log K
products now you know that all the
shortest paths or without loss of
generality simple and so they have
length at most n minus 1 so you only
have to repeat this log n times to get
all the distances and this will give you
that all pair shortest paths only has to
do roughly log and queries to this
business product turns out you can get
rid of the log so these problems
actually equivalent this was proven for
example by Fisher in mind 71
alright so now you know a distance
product is and now we can forget about
paths and graphs and just focus on
distances on distance product alright so
we're back to this picture i have shown
you this arrow and now i will use my
pointer okay now we'll do negative
triangle a distance product will show
the meat of the reduction again this
isn't 2010 a long time ago alright so
let me recap remind your hood negative
triangle is you have a graph it has some
edge weights on its edges we can even
assume they're integers and we'll given
this graph we want to say whether there
are AI de case or said when you take the
sum of their edge weights you get a
negative number you know say no
otherwise so there's a trivial cubic
time algorithm you try out ripples of
nodes and you check the condition and we
don't know how to do better again just
as usual I am fascinated by problems
where this happened so you can just
assume this happens for every problem I
say okay so so we will reduce distance
product to the simple looking problem
and will do this in two steps the first
step is to take an intermediate problem
we'll call it all pairs negative
triangles and in this problem we want to
know for every pair of nodes I and J are
they in some negative triangle so is
there K such that the sum of the weight
of I kids so w KJ and WJ I is actually
negative so I wrote it in this funny on
your way for a reason you'll see a
little of it in a little bit but it's
really it's the same things
okay so the first thing we'll do we'll
reduce distance products of this
intermediate problem and then we'll
convert an intermediate problem a
problem where you need to compete
something for about for all pairs of
nodes into something that only needs to
decide the single condition so I will
start with the first part and then I'll
show you the second part which you'll be
the second part will be the most
interesting part of the reduction okay
so let's take a distance product
instance and just as I showed you in the
reduction to distance product I can
convert it into a graph problem so given
two matrices a and B or you convert it
into a tripartite graph with partitions
I K&J the edges from I to K a correspond
to entries of a and the edges from k2j
correspond to interest in what B and
eyes are the same here so okay so we
know this already so now I'm going to do
something funny so suppose I start
putting edges between J&I and I
carefully pick some edge weights to put
on them so I start with this graph and
I'll make I start adding new address I
know now what do these new I just tell
us okay if we take this graph and we put
the new edges and feed it to a an
algorithm that solves all pairs negative
triangles in particular it will tell me
for every pair of nodes I and J and
these two partitions is there some K and
here search that I J&K formal negative
charge and so when you and we look at
this is actually an eight but ok so so
then you get is their case which is AI k
plus BK j is less than the weight or
less than a negative of the way the door
is stuck in here for
okay so if there is such a cake then
actually it's equivalent to asking
whether the minimum of a ik + + baking j
is less than this because if we have
some k for widget host and for in
particular for the one that achieves the
minimum it has to hold okay so what are
we saying we're saying that i can i can
put the bunch of numbers here and i can
check in parallel with a single call to
all pairs negative triangles whether my
guess is for the distance product and g
IJ is too big or just right towards or
too small so this tells me I can do
binary search and I can simultaneously
do the binary search for all entries I
and J and I do this like after each call
I change my numbers that i put here
depending on what the old pairs negative
triangle instance told me about I and J
and this is where I need it all I needed
it to tell me about all the pairs
because I want to be able to search all
right so I do simultaneous binary search
and oops and then I get my reduction now
there's something I'm sleeping under the
rug the binary search you will have to
we'll have a logarithmic dependence on
the weights okay so maybe I'm cheating
but it turns out there was some more
work you can get rid of that and you can
replace it with a log in fact so yeah
but you seem about the output of the all
pairs negative presence for each IJ
Perry tells you whether it tells me a
bit for each I j.pierre tells me is is
there a negative triangle between I&J
including IJ or not so gives me a
boolean matrix that's the output
so we get me something at the beginning
to general I assume you need coaster in
Phoenix so unique coasters medics um so
what's in the word remodel but we don't
even need that it just if the edge
weights are of size up to em they're
integers and I pay log M to do the stuff
but then I can get rid of it okay and
you can assume if you're worried about
the cost to to actually do the
computations assume that the integers
fit in the words and then okay
okay this step clear good so we have
this step now and we've reduced distance
product to some problem about triangles
but we have not gotten rid of the part
where we need to do things about all
pairs and this is where we were heading
so this is where this step comes in so
now we take this all pairs negative
triangle distance and convert it into a
just decision question is there any and
negative triangle in the graph I'll
start with the idea then I'll show you
the full proof so the idea is sort of I
I assume that my graph is tripartite
which you can assume without loss of
generality so now I have these
partitions I J&K and what I'm going to
do is for each of the partitions I'll
just split them up arbitrarily into
pieces of roughly the same size and now
pick the parameter s which will tell me
all the sizes so each I take junior and
I split into pieces of size s they'll be
an over as pieces here the same with K
in the same with I and then the first
attempt is I'm going to take every
triple of pieces I look at the induced
sub graph and I'll make a call to
negative triangle there and now we will
learn whether this triple of pieces
contains a negative triangle and if it
does then I will I can set this entry in
my output of all pairs net- triangles to
one ok we're not avoiding anything yet
because we still have to do all triples
and it might take us too long but but
the point is that if you did that then
your call to negative triangle is only
on pieces of size s instead of n so it
seems like we can do something with this
alright so now now that you know that
we've petitioned the graph into pieces
and we're doing stuff on triples of
pieces I'm going to give you the full
reduction so the reduction is as follows
let's say C is going to be my output
originally cell zeros and we'll fill it
up with once when I ever we learned that
IJ is and some negative triangle would
put a one there okay then we start
iterating the following process we take
every triple of pieces in turn and we
look at the engines sub graph well let's
say first we take I 1 j1 k1 take the
union of these nodes look at this induce
sub graph and then we check whether this
sub graph contains a negative triangle
and well it still has one we actually
find it okay finding actually you can do
with the detection algorithm is with
yourself or disability is not too hard
to show so you find some negative
triangle so this would be some a X and
ay Y and peace I and J and then with
some k over here and then we just record
in Maya and the output matrix that we
found a negative triangle there okay so
far is what I said on the previous slide
now the next thing we do is actually we
change the weight of this edge that we
just discovered this in a negative
charge we make it into an infinity and
that concludes the algorithm because
well the moment we learned that this
edge is isn't a negative triangle we can
just remove it this this is what
effectively we do when we set it to
infinity this edge will no longer be
reported ever to the algorithm so when
we remove it we remove it from the
entire graph so in particular from all
the pieces that we call the algorithm on
and so so the number of times we we ever
return the negative triangle is at most
n squared
this is the algorithm the reduction I
will analyze it on the next slide so all
right what's the run time okay first of
all the correctness should be clear we
actually kind of searching through
everything in the moment we find
something we recorded we just saved a
little bit a little bit of work by not
reporting things more than once so the
runtime is the number of triangles found
times the time to find a negative
triangle which is this plus the number
of triples that is it times the time to
assert that the triple no longer has a
negative triangle so this is the runtime
number of triples plus the number of
triangles phone there's a time that up
to to run the negative triangle
algorithm now the number of triples we
carefully picked to be n over s cubed
whereas with the size of each piece and
the number of triangles we found we
guarantee that it's no more than N
squared because we're guarantee that no
edge will be checked more than once so
okay and it only costs and the time to
do a negative triangle call on no graphs
of size s instead of n now we usually do
is we sort of balance things out let's
assume that the time to find a negative
triangle is n to the D for some d
hopefully less than 3 and then we
balance things so that s is then to the
one-third this makes this be the same as
n squared and when we do this we get
that if we had a negative triangle time
algorithm that's the runs again to the D
then we get an end to the two plus D
over three time algorithm for for all
pairs negative triangles now it's not
the same run time okay but I didn't say
I would give you that I said that
whenever this is so cubic this one will
be sub K week
and this is true so this is this is an
example of an adaptive reduction that's
fine grained and and if you notice it
fulfills all the definite the definition
and I showed you and it gets something
completely non-trivial so we have
similar reductions for other problems
but this is sort of
okay yeah the reason why you don't set
CF a ex-ac and cfa yacs 10 well the
question is why didn't I set these two
edges in the output to be this is
because i defined the all pairs negative
triangle that i only care about the
pairs between partitions I on Jay this
is that's why but yeah you could also
solve the other problem just change the
ok show you some names of I'm Jane okay
duty of the sometimes run the same
triple many times because maybe that
same triple is leading to many edges
right like when you set that edge which
you discover you set it to infinite but
will be there is another edge of the
triple well this is a tripartite graph
so the only triangles go like this the
moment I said this to infinity it cannot
appear in any more negative triangles
but your article is only giving you that
one edge maybe there is another edge in
that triple like 40 it could be that's
why I keep doing it while there's a
negative triangle I check it again is
there one I do it again until we've
exhausted all the negative child was in
the triple so yes so you don't only find
a single negative triangle the chip
would just keep doing it and this is why
we have to split the runtime into this
good all right so what we have shown is
the central part right here that sort of
makes everything work and I'll show you
a reduction now from the simple problem
to radius and we'll see how these things
typically go okay this was in 2014 a
year ago I guess okay so now we'll make
some changes to the negative triangle
problem which are true without loss of
generality the first thing is as we've
been doing so far we can assume the
graph is tripartite just because we can
just rip all the all the nodes and and
put the copy of each edge in the number
of triangles is preserved in a constant
factor and everything still works out
okay so we can assume this graph is
tripartite and we're just looking for
negative negative triangle and it will
have one node in each of the partitions
and the second thing we can assume is
that it's complete triport i graph just
because if the maximum edge way it was M
we can just put edges that have weight
them to represent the non majors and we
don't even have any infinity weights
that way as everything has weights
between minus M and M and it's a
complete try paragraph everything is
right okay this this helps us with
reductions doesn't like makes things
easier okay so I added this knowledge
and I put mine because mine is the
largest scituate alright so now how do
another modification in a negative
triangle problem we were asking if
there's a charge of negative some now
I'll just add some quantity to all the
edges in particular the largest edge
weight plus W where W is something
that's bigger than M and for some reason
it's not showing but okay this this foal
is supposed to be w greater than M
okay you imagine all right so now we
will do after we've done this what we
have is that instead of looking for a
triangle of weight less than zero we're
looking for a triangle of weight three
times this quantity because they have
three edges and trying to any Church got
to mixture and plus W on it okay so we
didn't change the problem too much we
just three weighted it a little bit and
this also makes all the edge weights
non-negative and okay so now what we'll
do is we're going to take the triangle
negative triangle instance new create a
graph out of it they will have four
layers so the original graph had
partitions a B and C and now we have a
layer that has a copy of them and of all
the nodes of a then would have a layer
with a copy of all the knobs of be a
copy of all the nodes of C and a cup a
second copy of all the nodes of a so we
have B and C appearing here but a gets
got split into two pieces and okay now
what we'll do is just for your SPECT
we'll put the weights the way between a
and B are between the parents bit of a
and B you know the first copy we put all
the weights just as they were in the
original graph between the respective
copies all right to know what will get
is that if so for any a and it's copy a
prime and this side will have a path of
length the shortest path will be the
length of the minimum triangle between
the contains a okay and if their minimum
triangle was less than 3 m plus 3w then
the distance between a and a prime will
be less than 3 M plus 3w we don't have a
very nice guarantee about a and anything
else so we'll add some edges
and we'll add an edge between a and the
no that's different from its copies or
any other node and its way to be 3n plus
2w so actually be less the 3m plus 3w
and what we've achieved now is that for
any node a its distances to the right
part are less than this quantity 3 M
plus 3w if and only if it's contained in
a negative charcoal in a triangle have
weighed less than three empties the
government so that's what we achieved
and we're trying to get something about
the radius and in order to do that will
force the node whose eccentricity is the
radius to be on this side and when we do
this then we were ensure that the radius
is less than this quantity if and only
if a this node has a negative triangle
in the original graph okay to do this we
had this bizarre thing here we add to
node Z and W there are roughly the same
in the sense that basically these nodes
here have where edge weights of the same
number n plus w2 x and y and some other
number two double NZ and these numbers
were chosen so that first every pair of
nodes here are close their distance to n
plus 2w and every node except for the
nodes in a is very far away from z NW so
this is how we chose them so every node
except for the nodes in a is far away
from GW in particular distance bigger
than 3n plus DW but the nose in a our
distance less than three M plus three
double so now what we get is the center
node must be in here and the radius is
less than three and plus 3w if and only
if there is a negative triangle in the
original graph
what is like those ages today are you
asking why we need these well okay it
just think about if we only had one then
this node can be the center we want to
avoid this so when when I put this note
here I made these all be closed and i
put this node can now be the center so i
make it not be the center because it's
far away from that one so I it's a
little tricky bit you have to do this
yeah what about paths that go like from
a to e by the red edge and then like I
up to see and then CUA can you guess
yeah yeah ok so there's another
technical things thanks so you have to
be careful because there's all these
paths here they go like this so you have
to make sure that they're not too short
and you this is why we have to pick W to
be large enough ok because and we know
that all the edge edges are have they
are bigger than W ok so in particular
this this path the way we've chosen if
it goes back and forth it gets to W on
to the 3 + 3 + + 4 W and now it becomes
bigger than what we want so you have to
make sure that all the pairs are
satisfied but if you pick the ways in
this way it works ok so this shows that
if you have a really really good
algorithm for radius it gives you a good
algorithm for negative triangle and a
good algorithm for this pass here we
didn't have to do anything fine-grained
we actually just got an instance of
roughly the same size so this is sort of
what you typically expect but we do have
the fine-grained part from all patients
pass to negative
ok questions
so ah that's what I said every no no and
I put this stuff to tell you that the
distances to all the other partitions
are small but it's not that important
you just pick the weights to work for it
to work out okay so what we've done so
far is we've covered everything I was
going to cover about Dan scraps we did
this part but this part and the yellow
direction we knew so this psycho is now
complete and all the other reductions
have some sort of similar flavor you
have to carefully construct the graphs
it doesn't always work we thought that
it will make it work for diameter but
things just don't work out
who's the end of dance crafts if you
don't do you have any questions on dance
crafts otherwise I'll move on to the
sparse graph since I'm a little bit slow
today all right so for dense graphs we
had these nice equivalences for sparse
graphs we don't have that yet so we get
for sports girls we get some sort of
hardness based on some conjectures just
like I mentioned last out yesterday and
here's something we can get okay this is
just repeating what I had before here
we're fighting against the N squared all
the parameters I mentioned you can solve
in a square time by just reducing them
to all pair shortest paths and even in
we have one weighted graph see for the
dense case the the problem is hard but
mainly because their weights when
there's no when the graphs are in the
way do we can solve them and sub cubic
time but in sparse graphs this the way
stones don't play much of a difference
it turns out that we even stuck on
unweighted graphs so right and again who
for all pair shortest paths even if we
solve it in as in optimal time for
sparse graphs would still be paying n
squared and here it's unclear why these
problems should require n squared
because they're just single integers so
and then again what about approximation
algorithms maybe when you approximate
things things you can do the linear time
and here's something we're able to show
we were able to show that you can
actually get some constant factor
approximation Xin sub quadratic time for
example for diameter in sparse graphs
you can get a 3 halves approximation in
let's say enter the 1.5 time or as the
same thing for radius and for all the
eccentricities you can get five thirds
approximation again an end to the 1.5
the median problem is easier much easier
when you're allow for approximations
you can get an approximation scheme the
runs are roughly linear time so somehow
when you have sums it's much easier to
approximate the one you have made
million so okay so this is all that's
known for approximation algorithms as as
far as I know and who actually show that
all these ratios three have 3,000 five
thirds are tight for sub quadratic
algorithms under some conjectures so for
me the most surprising was this five
thirds or no okay with child we thought
the minimum and the maximum
eccentricities can be approximated
within a factor of three halves why
can't we approximate all of them within
a factor of three halves but it turns
out if you want all of them somehow five
thirds of the right hands okay so here's
the sparse graph conjectures that we use
the first one is the orthogonal vectors
conjecture I mentioned yesterday which
is given two sets of n vectors each with
some may be slightly super logarithmic
dimension are the two vectors that are a
pogrom out and the conjecture was that
if you want to solve this problem on the
word wrap let's say it requires n to the
two- little of one time and i have
showed you this the proof of this
theorem that strongly th implies
orthogonal vectors conjectures so if you
believe strong eth you need to believe
this one too and then there is a
slightly weaker conjecture so this is
this other problem that I haven't
defined yesterday this is different so
here you're given two sets u and v of
subsets of some universe k of the
integers want to k where k is something
slightly super logarithmic and you want
to know is is there some set set here
the hits all of the sets here so by hit
i mean it contains some element of each
of the sets so is the hitting set
problem and
the heating's a conjecture is that this
problem also requires into the two-
little one time it has been studied
within the context of data structures in
one way or another and we thought it's
it's actually we can prove that it's
actually strictly horizontally it's
easier than orthogonal vectors so if you
if you believe the hitting second
gesture then you should believe the
Republic vectors conjecture you can
reduce hitting set orthogonal vectors so
okay so we have the these are the two
conjectures that we use in sparse
problems and ya know vector C but it's
not a lot of terminal vectors for if
you've translated into vectors it will
be there exists a vector and once said
that is not orthogonal to any of the
others I don't know it's kind of this is
make sense because it hitting set is a
set that intersects all other sets
exactly no I thing is there the SLR you
what it is that I like the fact you can
praise aspect also ok pressure is like
looking also praised this as subsets I
mean we can go back and forth were you
you're right there's some type mismatch
but but I like the type the name is the
right one
okay so we have these two conjectures
one is more believable than the other
but we can prove the following this is a
picture of some of the things we know at
least with respect to the parameters i
define you can reduce your toga no
vectors to beading three-halves
approximation in sub quadratic time for
the diameter and 4 5 thirds for the
eccentricities you can reduce heating
set to the median and approximating the
radius so so this is what we know and I
think in the amount of time i have i
would just show you this one which is
relatively simple okay so potentially
radius and median are easier that's
that's what you should get out of this
okay so here's a what we'll do we'll
take the problem of distinguishing where
the diameter of a graph is two or three
and will reduce orthogonal vectors to
this problem and this will mean that if
if we get a better than three halves
approximation algorithm for diameter in
particular we can distinguish between
the diameter being 2 and 3 and therefore
we can also solve orthogonal vectors and
K cmf sent case app for ok ok so the
reduction is very very simple pretty
fast to do so what you do is you take
the orthogonal vectors instance and will
create a tripartite graph out of it and
the left side will put a node for each
vector and on the right side will put
another load for each vector and then in
the middle we'll put a node for each
coordinate a vector well put the two
extra node X and Y just to help us with
distances then we'll do we'll put edges
from Y to everything on the right there
just from X to everything on the left
this guarantees of the distance between
any note on the left and you know the
night is at most three
okay and also guarantees that any nodes
on the same side or distance to now
we'll also put these edges between from
x and y 2 everything in the middle and
this also guarantees that any coordinate
is a distance to from any other
coordinate and everyone else so if the
diameter is 3 it better come from two
nodes one on the left and one on the
right because it cannot come from any
other pan so now we will put edges
between vectors and coordinates in the
following way for any vector V and any
coordinates see will put an inch if and
only if that vector is one in that
coordinate the same thing here will put
a 1 will put an edge between DN u if u
is 1 and coordinate d and this this
completes the reduction and what do we
know first of all we know that every
pair of nodes that is not one on the
left and one the right our distance to
and and now we get that for every pair
of nodes v and u on different sides
their distance to if and only if they
have a coordinate in which they both
want and if there is no such coordinate
they their distance is exactly 3 by
going through this x and y so now so
this means that the diameter is 3 if and
only if there is an orthogonal pair has
to otherwise so distinguishing between 3
and 2 tells you if there is an
orthogonal pair and yeah yes would get
your final vector from where the entries
are integers valid to 0 or 1 ah ok so
he's asking what happens to orthogonal
vectors of the entries are integers so
if if you work over the integers its we
think it's a strictly harder problem if
you work over a finite field you can
there's actually faster algorithms
right so this is a very simple reduction
and the way you do the radius reduction
is you take the hitting set problem and
translate it in a very similar way and I
think I don't have time like Thor okay
so I'll skip that one there's a
reduction I'll put the slide somewhere
there so a few words about radius and
diameter the funny thing is that every
algorithm we've had the worst for radius
also works for diameter and vice versa
so it's kind of annoying you can't prove
that they're equivalent the only place
where they differ is in the quantifiers
so one problem is about max max the
other one is about min max and it
actually makes them quite different
different when we try to prove
reductions we actually think the amateur
possibly easier than all pair shortest
paths in dense grass but or it might
just be hard to improve on and cube for
some completely different reason we
actually have some equivalence class
around diameter and dense graphs for
example if you want to approximate the
betweenness centrality of a vertex is
equal to the diameter problem okay so
here's some open questions and I'll
conclude with this can we get any
hardness for the diameter problem for
dense grass assume some maybe you assume
some other conjecture that's not all
pair shortest paths requiring and keep
done maybe something else can we explain
where we're stuck we don't have anything
yet can we make find some other
equivalent graph problems so far we've
mostly been working with shortest paths
related problems maybe we can think
about other things can we relate this
parson dense case there's something I
don't know what to say about the middle
those can we prove something like this
it doesn't enter the 1.9 algorithm for
spice dad I ammeter imply into the 2.9
for dance diameter no idea
maybe luck to my BSN okay so can we show
any approximation hardness for any
problem and dense graphs not for all
perils past because we know they can
approximate it with arrays algorithm in
line to do mega time but maybe some
other problems we can show some
approximation preserving reductions and
we haven't been able to do that for
doug's graphs and what about the actual
run times we get four three halves
approximations when we have a sparse
graph usually we get n to the 1.5 and
why can we do linear time so we don't
have a good answer for this and so this
concludes my talk and thank you now the
questions is it see that this feeling
because you can throw down like this
division between screens though this
exactly the same stuff that's in packing
it doesn't roll out to have some
asymptotic pitas or something like this
one like that word gets better
approximation it's my turds and the
distances like thousands and thousand
ten or something I mean like
approximation in the formic and no 1.2
times opt + 10 okay so here he's asking
is this do we only get two and some
hardness bit about distinguishing two
and three can we just get some a very
nice additive approximations right no we
cannot get additive approximations for
the same reason we have have reductions
showing that no constant not not even
know constant additive approximations
are possible against again assuming
talking all vectors you can prove you
know the mixed approximations are not
possible with some settings and yeah
you just put intermediate vertices along
every edge to stretch it out this will
show you between 2d and 3d but it's not
sufficient or maybe there is something
going on when you try to prove additive
approximations you have to do more work
that's our hands internal network
conjecture razor and it's very
believable because all right it's
bye-bye eh right but when can you
motivate that a bit back that they eat
insects conjunction because that's kind
of okay so the kidding said conjecture
is just you just modify their talking
erectors conjecture in a sense to change
the quantifiers of the reductions work
in a sense but we also try to solve it
because because we really believe it's
simpler right it's a simpler problem but
none of the techniques seem to work ok
so maybe so the reason why we consider
these reductions is because maybe we can
solve this problem and get some
intuition about what to do with when the
quantifiers are different and actually
this is a good question it comes comes
up in other problems that people have
studied a lot so there's these problems
and graphs that are similar to finding a
triangle so for example there's a
problem called simplicial vertex here
you're given you want to find a node
such that its neighbourhood is a click
ok so this is again it's a similar
quantifier so up there and it's believed
to be easier than triangle but it has
been studied for many many years by a
lot of researchers and the best
algorithm is to end to the Omega and so
there's a lot of different cases where
this sort of quantifiers what happens
yet we still don't have a better
algorithm and this is a studying this
problem is something that will allow us
to learn something more
boundary and so on from you need a
moment with a good question so the
question is what properties of the graph
in the reduction make the problems easy
or hard so one thing we noticed is that
if you look at the reduction the graph
has kind of small tree with if you saw
yesterday's lecture so the tree vyas is
log in our talaga so then we this will
give you some hardness for graphs for
getting algorithms in terms of tree with
and particularly led us to ask the
question what if what if you wanted an
FPT algorithm that runs a linear time
and has some running time that small in
terms of the tree with or other
parameters that follow from this
reduction and we were able to you know
this reduction already shows the two to
the whatever tree with lower bound to
the little of two with x n lower bound
or 10 to the 2 minus epsilon even but
you can also show an upper bound is
close to that and you can you can do a
lot of stuff like this and actually
still open what other parameters one can
explore